good evening and thank you so much for
joining us tonight at five o'clock i'm
sasha loftis violence in our valley
schools one teacher tells us she was
recently attacked by a student madison
kimbrough joins us live tonight with
more on her story madison
this is the first time we're hearing
directly from a ccsd teacher who was
assaulted on the same day that a school
board meeting took place on school
violence now take a look as they didn't
want to give their name or middle school
that she worked at she says she is now
contemplating whether teaching is
something she wants to continue as she
is a first year teacher this incident
happened during first period on friday
when an apparent fight broke out between
two girls when the teacher tried to stop
it she then ended up getting attacked in
the process stating that she was punched
several times with her hair pulled and
also tackled now she's left wondering
what her next move will be as she's
never experienced anything like this
before
it makes me question like
is this what i work so hard to get into
i mean i woke up the next today and i'm
sore and my head hurts and i'm kind of
still wrapping my head around what
happened
as for the students involved both were
suspended she says faculty had her fill
out a report but then she ended up
working the rest of the day when she
came to it was her other students
surrounding her asking if she was ok
when the numbers that we obtained from
ccsd it shows that school violence is up
by
5300 over 5300 cases within this school
year alone reporting live madison
kimbrough live local now